It is no secret
that we love all things design
on this show.
I wanted it to be a big part of this show
'cause it's a big part of my life.
So when we heard the design dilemma of our next guest
we were excited to help create a brand new segment,
we're calling Design Court.
(gavel clacks)
(audience cheers)
Both sides will state their cases.
And by end of this trial,
we will reach a design verdict.
(gavel clacks)
Yeah!
(audience cheers)
Take a look at the Philpott's design dilemma.
Hi Drew, my name is Cass.
My name is Ted and we're the Philpotts.
We are hoping that you can help us
settle a design issue in our home.
Basically we've been in this house
for about 15 years.
We have redone all the other rooms
to suit our lifestyle.
With the exception of this one.
The room is called the back 40
because it tends to be the catchall for the house.
And I would like to see it be more of a tranquil space
a quiet place to escape everything from the house.
Clean lines, quiet colors, calm furniture,
and a place just to retreat.
What I'd like to do
is something a little bit more entertainment style,
pub style, game room style, theater style.
So maybe a big TV, a shuffleboard table, some large couches.
Something comfortable for myself, our friends,
my daughter and her friends
to hang out and relax a little bit.
So a day in the life of the Philpotts,
you see we don't agree.
So we need help.
(audience cheers)
Well, we could not start a trial
without Drew Crew member
and my partner in crime of design, Mikel Welch.
Hey friend!
(audience cheers)
Good to see you again.
I hate the idea of working against you.
Usually we're a team.
I know, but you know what,
a little fun banter never hurt.
Let's do this.
Let's do it.
All right, well, it is time to meet our design litigants
Cass and Ted Philpott.
Come on out!
(audience cheers)
(dramatic music)
Hi, hello!
Well, Design Court is now in session.
Uh-oh.
All right, Mikel is representing Ted
and I will be representing Cass.
Now, Cass, let's start with your opening statement.
Please address the court with your vision for the room.
So we have such crazy busy lives as it is
that I feel like our home should be our sanctuary
and we should have a space to retreat
from all the togetherness.
So I would like to see the room,
be a design that's for solitude, peace,
and just some alone time.
And is it correct that you read
two to three books a week?
I do.
Possibly a day.
Oh wow.
I am an avid reader.
Do you hear that Mikel?
I heard it.
All right.
Ted, state your case?
She's not wrong.
Our life is hectic and she has a beautiful, comfortable room
in the living room and the bedroom
and the patio outside to read plenty of books
as long as she wants to.
That's a lot of room.
Right, we also do a lot of entertaining
and we need a space
that brings a little bit of life to the house.
Some sort of game room,
someplace where our younger daughter
and her friends can hang out.
Someplace I can unwind and kind of get away
from the hectic life that she's trying to escape.
Well, I thank you, councils
for excellent opening statements.
Good arguments.
Well, the jury is still out.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪